é bom pessoal meu é conhecimento sobre o
direito à cidade e se intensificou
quando eu é um estudante de design
resolvi fazer o mestrado relacionado é
pra estudar um escritório de design que
é dividir as suas atividades do dia a
dia entre trabalhos comissionados e não
comissionados
eu queria entender como que funcionava a
estrutura do escritório que tinha até
grandes empresas mas que também dedicava
o seu dia a dia pra projetos não
comissionados que resultavam em ações
ativistas é o escritório em questão foi
o grupo bijari em são paulo e a maioria
dos projetos ativistas do grupo estavam
relacionados ao espaço urbano ea partir
daí eu acabei nem intensificando meu
conhecimento a respeito de eletrificação
especulação imobiliária e o direito à
cidade o direito à cidade que implica no
direito habitar a viver a cidade
experiência lá a festa a um rolezinho
por exemplo é o direito aos equipamentos
e serviços básicos é o direito na
participação da gestão do do espaço do
espaço público vocês por exemplo
moradores de indaiatuba não gostariam de
decidir junto com a prefeitura o que
poderia acontecer na sociedade é o que
poderia acontecer no parque ecológico
por exemplo numa praça perto da sua casa
é o direito à cidade a gestão
democrática da cidade ela está no
estatuto da cidade que é uma lei federal
de 2001 e que estabelece entre outras
coisas diretrizes para garantir a gestão
democrática do espaço
você como pedestre por exemplo às vezes
não acha que o carro ele têm mais
prioridade do que você existe mais
espaço do que eu é pra o carro do que
pra você pedestre
a gente tem um plano de mobilidade é
plano nacional de mobilidade que também
é uma lei e que estabelece entre outras
coisas é a priorizar o pedestre
os veículos não motorizados sobre os
motorizados ea equidade do espaço
público eu como moradora de são paulo
na época eu vivia de perto essa
desigualdade entre carro e pedestre e aí
pra mostrar pra falar um pouquinho disso
trouxe essa imagem que ela é uma imagem
de um do google maps do bairro da
baixada do glicério em são paulo é um
bairro que já realizei um trabalho lá
por isso que eu trouxe essa imagem aqui
a gente tem uma escola pública ali em
cima
aqui nessa imagem eu marco os espaços
que esta área construída aqui a gente
tem acesso à escola que eu falei aqui na
outra parte eu marco a área voltada ao
pedestre a calçada
notem que aqui a gente quase não tem
cansada é inexistente
aqui a área de travessia e esse espaço
destinado ao automóvel a circulação eo
estacionamento de automóveis é notem que
aqui tem uma área que é que faz parte da
área construída grande parte é dos
locais que das áreas é dentro da área
construída de grande parte das áreas
construídas também tem estacionamento
hoje em dia né não é notem que a área
vermelha é bem maior área voltada ao
carro leito carroçável é bem maior do
que a área azul do pedestre né
e ainda tem um cara que estacionou o
carro na calçada
eu pra fazer essa imagem eu me baseei no
no estudo do el michael andersen que é
um especialista em mobilidade urbana e
ele fez esse mesmo essa esse mesmo
estudo em várias cidades do mundo ele
chama isso de arrogância do espaço
urbano é bom na época do meu mestrado eu
acabei intensificando meu meu
conhecimento em relação à cidade direito
à cidade e
trabalhava num num grupo de designers
que chamava grupo design ok e acabei
conhecendo a carol ferris do cidade azul
e ela mostrou pra gente o conceito de
park hyatt em são francisco na
califórnia que eles foram pioneiros é em
realizar os patrões criar um manual de
instalação o propac ti e bom que é um
parque de ti não o parque é uma área de
lazer e convívio que ocupa o carro o
espaço do carro é aguardando a área da
calçada priorizando o pedestre quando
conheci esse projeto eu fiquei
apaixonada e feliz gente a gente tem que
fazer alguma coisa dessas em são paulo e
aí a gente se juntou um grupo de
designers arquitetos um instituto de
mobilidade urbana uma empresa de eventos
e passamos a pedir a agenda em todas as
secretarias da cidade de são paulo pra
que os que a secretaria se conhecessem o
projeto entendessem a sua importância a
idéia nossa ideia inicial era que é o
parque elite se tornasse uma política
pública para a cidade de são paulo
pouco tempo depois a gente conseguiu
realizar uma ação é de dois dias a gente
instalou dois para eles em lugares
diferentes na cidade é durante quatro
dias e dois parques durante quatro dias
com a parceria da prefeitura e de outros
parceiros também ea idéia que ela sente
é como que apresentar o conceito na
cidade de são paulo e sentir é é a
reação da população nessa época nesses
quatro dias a gente fez uma pesquisa
para saber se as pessoas gostavam gostar
ou não gostar
depois disso um mês depois a gente
instalou um outro parque de ti nada na
uma travessa da avenida paulista e se
ficou instalado durante um mês ele teve
uma agenda cultural ativa um parque ele
pode ter uma agenda cultural pode ter um
gestor do parque e que proponha agenda
cultural praquele lugar e foi durante a
bienal de arquitetura ea ideia que era
debater neste segundo
momento com é a secretaria é de são
paulo como que é a gente iria fazer
acontecer essa política pública
notem aqui que o parque de ti ele deve
ser acessível a partir da calçada ele
tem que ter floreiras assento ele tem
que ter é para fico no estacionamento da
bicicleta e ele não deve ser privatizado
todo participante tem que ter uma placa
de espaço público para evitar é a sua
privatização
bom um ano depois é que a gente ter
começado essa maratona de visitas
secretaria de instalação desses dois
para aqueles que também era um pacto
temporário
o prefeito da cidade são paulo haddad
assinou o decreto é regulamentando o uso
ea instalação de espaços de parquímetros
na cidade e esse é o primeiro parque
definitivo da cidade ele está lá até
hoje também é no mesmo lugar onde estava
ali para o pleito anterior que era
temporário
ele está numa travessa da avenida
paulista e bom é claro que o parque ele
não resolve todas as nossas nossos
problemas de mobilidade urbana mais uma
política de patriot para a cidade ela
traz consigo uma série de coisas boas
como por exemplo os cidadãos passaram a
discutir com a prefeitura é o uso
adequado do espaço público na cidade
passa também o a ha ha ha serem criadas
novas políticas um olhar melhor para a
cidade passa a ser criadas novas
políticas de mobilidade urbana e aumenta
o espaço público por pedestres na cidade
além de põe em questão o espaço é
destinado ao carro hoje na cidade de são
paulo a gente tem 89 parquímetros
instalados pela iniciativa privada
iniciativa privada pode ser é uma pessoa
física pode ser um comércio o clube a
uma escola
hoje qualquer qualquer cidadão pode
instalar um
a crítica é na frente da sua casa ou
comércio escola bar e etc e tem 32
parques instalados pela prefeitura de
são paulo
bom esse grupo que se engajou para que é
os para que eles se tornassem realidade
na cidade de são paulo
parte dele hoje faz é forma o grupo
design o que é desculpa o coletivo leve
a falha é o coletivo leve trabalha com o
urbanismo tático é entre outras coisas o
que nós somos arquitetos e designers
urbanismo tático ele visa é através de é
ações flexíveis e de rápida
implementação entender é o que aquela
comunidade um bairro local necessita e
aí pra isso a gente faz uma pesquisa de
campo a gente interage com a comunidade
local para só depois realizar um projeto
a gente acredita que projetos é que não
não aconteça esse projeto é esse
processo da interação com a comunidade
local com a população eles podem muitas
vezes ser um projeto é que pode acabar
sendo projeto errado naquele determinado
local é um dos projetos que a gente fez
agora faz pouco tempo que eu tenho muito
orgulho de ter participado é um projeto
para crianças no bairro do glicério são
paulo o bairro que eu falei que já tinha
feito um trabalho aqui é uma imagem da
fachada de uma das casas na baixada do
glicério
é a gente é o coletivo leve foi
convidado pela ong criança cidade que é
uma ong que faz um trabalho muito bonito
mais de dois anos ali na região eles
trabalham com as crianças os seus
familiares numa metodologia de escuta
das crianças dos seus desejos e dos seus
anseios e tentar tornar esses dg desejos
anseios em realidade e o long convidou o
coletivo leve para poder pensar os
espaços públicos para as crianças na
cidade já é o bairro do glicério é um
bairro que possui oito cortiços essa
região
três escolas públicas alguns institutos
sociais e é listado pela prefeitura de
são paulo como uma região é em situação
de vulnerabilidade
a amm ea ideia desse convite era poder
pensar o espaço público para essas
crianças que é grande parte delas pelo
menos as crianças em cortiçada elas
ficam grande parte do dia na rua porque
na sua casa não tem muito espaço pra
poder é brincar e nem é muito agradável
às vezes a mãe mãe da criança para a rua
porque é melhor ficar na rua do que
dentro de casa é um e hoje em dia e tem
hoje em dia as crianças é uma regra das
crianças não brincam mais na rua nem
aqui a gente tinha uma situação um pouco
diferente é bom
a ideia é do dos do coletivo leve e da
criatividade foi de criar intervenções
ali no bairro
em alguns lugares do bairro e essas
intervenções elas seriam conectadas por
circuitos criados circuitos lúdicos para
criança experiências lúdicas para as
crianças pelas com viverem melhor ali na
na rua no bairro é a criança que brinca
na rua que realiza atividades ao ar
livre
ela é promove o seu senso de comunidade
porque ela acaba brincando na escola
como na escola que ela tá brincando com
crianças da mesma idade né
ela acaba encontrando crianças de outras
cidades e crianças menores o que acaba
aumentando seu senso de responsabilidade
é crianças com outros conhecimentos e
que acaba aumentando o seu senso é só
senso de sociabilidade também aumenta a
atividade cognitiva porque quando a
criança brinca ao ar livre ela acaba se
relacionando com o espaço aumentando sua
percepção com espaço entendendo os
limites e até aprendendo como lidar com
o inesperado ea criança quando brinca na
na rua ela aumenta sua relação com a
cidade
com o bairro e aumenta seu senso
comunitário e essa criança vai ser um
futuro cidadão né
quer dizer a criança já é uma cidadã
desculpa é bom e pensando nos circuitos
lúdicos né
a idéia é é para realizar esse processo
a gente demorou quase um ano né então
realizamos oficinas com as crianças
oficinas discuta oficinas de desenhos
produtos passam com caixas de papelão e
lego até chegar ao produto final é ua
onde cria cidade convidam outros
artistas pra deixarem a os circuitos é
bonito com grafite música etc entre nós
ficamos responsáveis pelo mobiliário
estariam daquelas naqueles pontos de
intervenção que eu mostrei pra vocês
e aqui tem algumas imagens dos
mobiliários que fizemos
a idéia do mobiliário ela promoveu os
circuitos né
promover a interação entre as crianças a
motricidade infantil minimização de
material é e à impossibilidade de
acúmulo de lixo que era um grande
problema na região eu tenho um sonho de
criar um espaço público infantil quem
sabe um dia e quem sabe em algum lugar
né
e aí com esse projeto a gente acaba
trazendo é transformando a rua para
aquelas crianças né e o senso de
pertencimento com o lugar e bom eu sou
designer faço parte do coletivo leve
também fazem parte do de um instituto
que trabalha com direito a cidade chama
instituto a cidade precisa de você e eu
hein
além de designer digo que sou
empreendedora social eu queria muito vir
falar com vocês aqui em indaiatuba para
poder quem sabe fazer criar novas
conexões e tentar fazer é fazer valer
essas leis existentes bom obrigada
[Aplausos]